andrew roberts author of Napoleon and
Wellington the Battle of Waterloo and
the great commanders who fought it I'll
take a cue from your introduction why
another book on Napoleon and Wellington
well there are no floral books on
Napoleon and an awful lot on Wellington
but this actually is the first one that
is about both men the way they
interacted and the way they thought
about one another and the way they
fought one another so there is a little
area I think uncovered who were they
well and Napoleon was the Emperor of
France he made himself Emperor at the
end of the French Revolution and he was
the conqueror of Europe up until 1815
when the great back at Waterloo was
fought against the Duke of Wellington
who was another self-made soldier who
later went on to become Prime Minister
of Britain when was Napoleon born the
poem was born on the 15th of August 1769
three months after Wellington we don't
know the exact date of Wellington's
birth because we don't even know where
he was born his son his father the Earl
of Mornington didn't bother to register
him so in that rather aristocratic way
that they had in the 18th century you
never got around to it so but we do know
that it was within three months of one
another there was the first of many
coincidences really about these two
great men okay the date again was 77069
how long did each man live well
Wellington lived to a ripe old age 82
but unfortunately Napoleon and there are
lots of different theories about why he
might have died that he died in his
early fifties at the age of 51 in 1821
so the Battle of Waterloo what was the
importance of it
well it really decided the fate the
destiny of Europe for a hundred years
there was not another great European
conflagration until the first world war
and so it was a vital moment really in
the in the history of the development of
Europe politically but also militarily
it was a it was one of those great
watershed moments the equivalent I
suppose in America would be the Battle
of Gettysburg where did you get the idea
for the book well I've been fascinated
by these people ever since I was seven
years old I was its
where we of some of my friends would
pretend to be a Napoleonic and others
would be wedding taylean they'd fight
against one another who's just an excuse
for a scrap frankly in front of
schoolchildren way that I love that
period and it's been sitting in the back
of my mind I just finished a very big
book a thousand page book on Lord
Salisbury the British and prime minister
and I wanted to do something that was
going to be a bit more fun than than
that where'd you go school I went to
Cambridge University but obviously when
I was a schoolboy it was just the prep
school in sorry called Cranley has great
fun place now we're in London for this
where is Suri compared to where we are
it's um it's the county south of where
we are now there's a picture in the book
and your books got some colour photos in
it where is this that's at Apsley house
the home of the Duke of Wellington here
in London it's a vast statue by Canova
Antonio Canova the the great sculptor of
Napoleon when he was first Consul of
France absolute house for Americans is
located where in London it's bang in the
middle it's the old address used to be
number one London which was allograft
address it's on Hyde Park Corner really
very close to all of the the shopping
and the the big hotels it's it's a
lovely beautiful house built again in
the 18th century and it contains many of
the treasures of the Wellington family
now this statue you say in your book
that the Brits paid something like 66
thousand pounds yeah an 1860 an enormous
amount of money it was bought it was
bought for the for the Duke of
Wellington to thank him for the victory
at the back of Waterloo and it was
lugged over with you can imagine how
many people to place in the stairwell of
the house actually housed and it was it
was a gift from a grateful nation so I
mean again this is the Duke of
Wellington's house and that Waterloo
what happened
well the the French were expected to win
they had many more men than the British
but Wellington lured Napoleon into a
trap because he knew in a way that
Napoleon didn't that the Prussian army
there later the German army was coming
to his rescue so just as the French
we're about to break through the British
lines they managed to be held off in one
of the toughest and the most aggressive
engagements really to be seen in human
history and then the Germans came and
stove in the French right flank and and
won the day how tall is that statue you
know it's huge it's I think about 18
feet it's obviously much much larger
than life but it's also really Napoleon
didn't like it even though it makes him
look like a Greek god and gives him the
most fantastic physique and everything
he didn't like it because he thought it
had actually gone too far although
Canova is the probably the greatest
sculpture of the of the period he
actually had the whole thing boxed up
and left in the Louvre Palace in Paris
in order not for people not to see it
because he thought that it was it was
just totally over the top so you talk
about when you talk about these men them
whether or not they're modest or or
whether they you know and I had a big
ego and in case of the Duke of
Wellington modest well he actually I
don't believe he was modest everybody
happened till now has assumed that he
was the personification of the of the
British Victorian gentleman as modesty
is very important part of that but he
rather enjoyed collecting collecting the
world medals certainly but also titles
he wound up at the end and he died at a
huge funeral service for him innocent
Paul's Cathedral they the Garter king of
arms read out all his titles and it took
about 20 minutes just to read out the
various princedoms and dukedoms and
things he managed to collect over the
course of his career not really the mark
of a modest man I don't think okay why
would he want that huge statue in his
house because he had a
a very real pride of having defeated
Napoleon who had threatened Britain for
23 years
he nearly invaded us in 1805 and he was
the greatest threat really between the
Spanish Armada and and the time of the
Kaiser or even adult Hitler so really it
was a wonderful thing to have defeated
him and he was tremendously proud of
that and to look at the man that you
beat every day as you walk up and down
the stairs must have given him an
incredible kick any idea any idea what
would have happened if Napoleon had won
at Waterloo well the the fact was that
the French and the Austrians as well who
also on our side were bearing down on
him but if he had defeated the British
and Prussians and the the British army
would have been forced to reembarked
rather like it did at Dunkirk in the
Second World War he would have had to
have reembarked back to the the coast
anyone that wasn't captured and he would
have reestablished himself he had beaten
the the Russians and the Austrians 15
times before in the course of his of his
long warfare and career and I think he'd
have probably didn't have done it again
he'd have reestablished himself as
Emperor and perhaps you would have
France and Empire today rather than a
than a republic you'd have a map in here
of Waterloo where is it it's in Belgium
it's just six miles
sorry twelve miles south of Brussels the
capital of Belgium in Europe and why
were they fighting in that location at
that time they were fighting there
because the Emperor had been in exile on
the island of Elba little island in the
Mediterranean off Italy the coast of
Italy and he'd escaped from exile and in
20 days completely astonishingly short
period of time those days before rail
travel or and or any thought of motorcar
he had got to Paris and had rebuilt his
empire the men had flocked his standard
his armies and legions were run were
fully stocked and he wanted to take on
the force to the north that was
commanded by the Duke of Wellington
that if he was able to defeat Wellington
he being with the chance of of
reestablishing himself on the throne of
France forever back in 1815 how many
people were there in France and how many
people in Great Britain we had there was
an enormous disparity and I think the
the whole of the population of Great
Britain which of course in those days
also included Ireland was only about 25
million whereas in France it was close
to 40 million and that of course is very
important for the the understanding of
why the Russian campaign the war of 1812
that Leo Tolstoy wrote about in war and
peace was so important because the
Russians didn't have that many more
people living there than in Russia from
the French and once the French had
completely dominated Europe and were
able to take levies of troops from all
the other European countries they were
able to launch this incredible invasion
of Russia which when it went wrong and
of course the snows came was the reason
that Napoleon's power was blunted go
back to those figures again sort of
forty million people in France today
they're right around 60 million I'm 70
and and then in Great Britain you have
25 million then today Great Britain is
it depends how you count it but about 60
I'm growing much you know much know
hundred years know and if you think
about what would have happened to the
American population in exactly those two
hundred years I mean it's exponential
and you're what about twenty two hundred
and twenty million or so you mentioned
actually 288 million well I mean that's
astonishing isn't it because if you
think about what it would have been in
1815 it just doesn't bear any kind of
comparison you mentioned that 23 years
what were what were those 23 years what
did Napoleon do during those years well
when he started he had the most
incredibly meteoric rise he shot up like
a star he was astonishing he started at
the age of as a in his in his late teens
as a captain of artillery and in by the
age of 26 he was commander of all French
armies in Italy the commander-in-chief
of the of the
you literally he fought a series of
utterly brilliant campaigns in against
the Austrians in Italy who were trying
to to run Italy at the time and by
literally three years later he was in a
position to declare himself dictator of
France and five years after that he
became Emperor of France all entirely
done through his own merits and through
the the work and the risks that he took
yeah a figure in there of something
between five and six million people were
killed during that time three across the
whole of Europe this was it was a it was
a massive long European war it involved
every single state there were no
neutrals in the in the Napoleonic Wars
they were everybody was touched right
from the north and down to down to
Africa it went into he gave marched into
Cairo and once there he marched into
Moscow and literally every capital in
Europe fell to him
except of course from London you say
that Napoleon and Wellington never met
they never met they came within 200
yards of one another at the back of
Waterloo I think I've established that
Wellington saw Napoleon through his
telescope on several occasions in an
early parrot early appearance but they
never actually met they came close to
meeting after the Battle of Waterloo as
well when Napoleon decided to surrender
to the British but Wellington didn't
accept his his surrender because he was
in the wrong place at the time and they
wanted to get Napoleon off by boat away
from France and not bring him back to
Paris because he had this incredibly
electric effect on the Parisian mob they
talked about books they leased in our
country they mentioned three people that
the most books have been written about
Jesus Napoleon and Lincoln why so many
books about Napoleon I think that he was
a elemental force he has this ability to
touch many people's lives in ways that
they quite often don't expect he was a
man who was entirely self-made he
was a highly intelligent self educated
man and his witticisms and his aphorisms
and his jokes are superb and their whole
books written just to his about his his
sense of humor rather like Winston
Churchill or Oscar Wilde or no coward I
think that good lines accreted to him in
the way that they do
- well sail'd stories the barnacles
attached but nonetheless he did say we
know he did say an awful lot of the of
the brilliant things that he said he was
also a builder he built some of the
finest architecture in Paris that's
still there today some of the most
wonderful bridges and the Arctic
triomphe for example was his brainchild
and he also set down the laws by which
France was governed really up until the
present day and the basis of the laws
his code Napoleon as he called it
forming the basis of the European
Union's laws as well so he had a
far-reaching intellect which which
touches us today but the trouble was in
the end he was a mega maniac he thought
that he was going to be able to roll a
rule the whole of Europe and that was
the thing that led to his downfall when
it was coinciding with the military
genius of the Duke of Wellington Aerys
height well first of all half dog was he
oh well there's a huge debate there's
been a 70 year debate over how tall he
was the The Times Literary Supplement
here in London has had this very
long-running debate because I think that
the the French inch was slightly smaller
than the English inch in the 18th
century and so that has caused
complications with this but we can tell
that from a spy hole that he drills
through the through the wall and his
house in santolina to be able to keep an
eye on on people and we know it was
drilled by him and of course we can
therefore tell how high is his eye was
although we don't know whether or not he
was wearing boots at the time I might
have added an extra G but I would say
that the historians seemed to coalesce
around
height of five foot five and how big was
yeah how much do you weigh do you
well this fluctuated enormously when he
was on campaign he would be especially
when he was when he was riding and he
would be Fiat he was he started off as a
thin young man and everybody mentions
how thin he was by the time he was taken
to campaign to campaign in his coach and
he had been Emperor for eleven years
he was quite an overeater and he did get
to a really very large amount seventeen
stone also how many times was he married
he's married twice the first time for
love to Josephine the Empress Josephine
who was a great beauty again a wit but
was unfaithful to him and who he quickly
fell out of love with it was an
incredibly passionate affair when it
when it began but when he discovered
that she was sleeping with some of his
brother officers this he then was
unfaithful to to her and had a series of
mistresses two of whom astonishingly
enough also slept with the Duke of
Wellington as I as I mentioned in my
book and how do you know that well
because they in their very old age and
they admitted it to two close friends
who noted it in Diaries and papers and
it comes down we also know from the
amounts of money that the Duke of
Wellington would give these these
girlfriends of his to have their room
their dresses remade and their to have
their hair done we've found all the
accounts of their own hairdressers and
it's very unlikely that a man would
would pay quite large amounts of money
to do that just for a friend who is it
Napoleon's second wife his second wife
was called Mary Louise the Archduchess
mary louise who was the daughter of the
Emperor of Austria and although of
course it was a political decision to to
marry her her family had ruled Austria
for six hundred years that also became
quite a love match and it wasn't really
until the
the Emperor of Austria himself had to go
to war against Napoleon and Mary Louise
had to choose between her husband and
her father where her loyalties lay that
that that marriage also hit the rocks
how many children here well there are
illegitimate children and legitimate
ones there's only one legitimate child
who was called the king of Rome a-also
Napoleon who some Napoleon aschool
napoleon ii he died only 10 years after
his father he was brought up in the
court of his grandfather the Emperor of
Austria and because the name Napoleon
was felt to be so threatening to to
French society he was never allowed to
live in France where did the name
Napoleon Bonaparte come from and I know
it was spelled to your wife yes it was
and it came from Italy there's a ancient
Saint Saint Napoleon Bonaparte actually
was born aparte which was two words and
that is thought - there's also debate
over this even thought to have derived
from France and the British always used
to put the you in the name boo on a part
in order to emphasize the unfriend Ness
of Napoleon who of course was born on
the island of Corsica and off the coast
of France and Italy and so they they did
this as a way to to irritate Napoleon
emphasize his foreign las' what would it
mean being born in Corsica at that time
well Corsica was a was a land of
banditry it was being constantly fought
over who was going to be who's going to
control it
the Italian city-state of Genoa owned it
sold it to France
it was then captured by Britain the
Corsican themselves role rose in Revolt
every five years or so and brigand
leaders who were often actually quite
quite impressive and indecent farsighted
statesman as Sir James Boswell there dr.
Johnson's friend found out but it really
toughened you up and
he was born the pony was born whilst his
mother was actually on campaign with her
husband in in the in the mountains so it
was a it was a tough from early
upbringing the 23 years that he was in
power or what years again well really
that he was that he was fighting and
France declared war against Britain in
1793 and that carried on for 23 years
until Wellington's victory at Waterloo
how many brothers did here he had four
brothers and he made each of them kings
at different times none of them were
really up to up to the mark bayley had
none of his genius but they were helpful
to him in running parts of the of the
Empire he had made one the king of
Holland and other king of Spain and so
on
they orally named their names were Lucia
then you had this thing I think was the
was the second oldest he was a
fascinating one in that he happened to
help Napoleon at the time of his at the
time of his coup d'etat Jerome was also
quite important he was the king of
Westphalia Joseph was the king of Spain
and he was unfortunate in that
Wellington overthrew him and of Jerome
in fact very interesting eater Romans
and wife first wife was Wellington's
and brother's ex-wife so Napoleon and
Wellington were in fact related via Vlad
their two brothers and one divorce how
do you keep track roles well it's part
of the double historian actually it's
great fun frankly I
I love them I love doing the archive
work I started asking at his height how
many soldiers he had under his command
meaning Napoleon yeah well and he
crossed the river Nieman into Russia and
with six hundred thousand the largest
army that had ever been seen in Europe
since the days of the Roman Empire and
the combination of a captured Moscow but
then Moscow burnt burnt to the ground
two thirds of it did and he was forced
to retreat back to France and the
retreat from Moscow and cost him three
quarters of his army four hundred and
fifty thousand men perished and only a
hundred and fifty thousand came back how
was that going down in France well it it
caused a mini revolution but not one
that the podium wasn't able to quell
simply by going back and and presenting
himself he also of course was a terrible
manipulator of the truth his propaganda
machine was very important to him and so
the government newspapers put out that
the actual defeat hadn't been as bad as
it as it had first been rumored and it
wasn't until much later on when the men
didn't return that France fully
understood the level of the horror
there's one tiny little fact in your
book that's American and that is that
you found a Napoleon Wellington high
school somewhere in the state of
Missouri how did you find out and if you
haven't been there I haven't been there
now and but I was giving a speech in
Fulton Missouri the I've got a honorary
Doctorate from from Westminster College
there and I was giving a speech about
Winston Churchill and I drove fast it
was something that that lodged in my
memory I made a note of it and the
importance of Fulton
importance of Fulton is that it was
there in march 1946 that Winston
Churchill attempted unsuccessfully at
the time interestingly enough to open
the world's eyes to the threat of
communism and basically told the British
and the Americans that Russia was not
the the friendly power that it had been
during the during the Second World War
but actually that they ought to wake up
and realize that there was a cold war
going on so it was one of the most
important speeches in retrospect of the
century however at the time it was
considered to be war mongering rhetoric
and we know it as the iron curtain
speech we do it was the speech in which
he said that from stet into it's down to
the Danube there was going to be an Iron
Curtain that effectively had heard
landed and there were three or four very
important the countries that had
hitherto been seen as part of the West
and that of course we didn't consider it
to be again part of the West until the
fall of the Berlin Wall and in 1989 and
what led to you getting an honorary
degree from Westminster College
well I'd written a few books on Winston
Churchill and he got another one coming
out next month in fact and he has got a
library there dedicated to him and the
continuation of what they do to keep
Churchill's memory alive at Fulton is
absolutely fantastic and I was very
honoured to be invited to to give a
lecture that today where do you live
full-time I live in Knightsbridge in in
London just a few doors down from
Harrods department store I think that's
probably the way that and are you
attached to school or is this full-time
job right no it's a name type I wouldn't
have the time I didn't think to to to
teach or mock exam papers or anything
like that I and kept pretty busy doing
this
now this napoleon in wellington book
that we have here was originally
published here in this country when it
was published in April 2001 and the
United States is published by Simon &
Schuster and I wonder in the in in this
book the lead blurb on the back is from
somebody by the name of Henry Kissinger
was that the same blurb you had on the
book here in Great Britain
it wasn't no and I sent a copy to dr.
Kissinger after it was published and and
he obviously very kindly gave me
something to put on the back of that it
was something actually that my
publishers organized Weldon myself and
I'm very pleased they did they fit all
the help because what we have to
remember is that he has an amazing locus
standi and not just obviously as the
historian of diplomacy but also his
latest book but also um he wrote a book
about meta Nicky and castle ray and
Talley round three of the great European
Statesman of the time of Napoleon and
Wellington and so he really doesn't know
his stuff when it comes to that period
he says Andrew Roberts has reexamined
between 1973 Europe's two greatest
generals their inevitable battle at
Waterloo and its impact on history
Napoleon and Wellington is an absorbing
book well researched and rich and new
and interesting detail valuable both as
a biography and military history but you
also have another connection with Henry
Kissinger well yes I'm going to write
his biography I've been asked by Alfred
not to do the sort of life of him it's
not going to be an authorised life in
that dr. Kissinger is not going to have
the right to blue pencil anything I
write he probably won't read anything I
am I right before it's published but he
is giving me cooperation for allowing me
into his papers at the Library of
Congress 30 tons of them I've been told
so that was going to be quite a few
quite a few years I don't have to hand
in the book until 2006 so what have you
Mary's working it I have met him yes I
met him on a couple of occasions and
I've got on very well he's obviously a
tremendously impressive figure why do
you want to go from Winston Churchill to
Napoleon and Wellington to Henry
Kissinger what's the connection Henry
Kissinger it will be the first living
person that I've I've written about all
my other people have been have been
safely dead and I well I find it a quite
a challenge I don't shy from controversy
it's very clear that dr. Kissinger is a
pretty controversial figure in America
probably the most controversial American
living today I would have thought with
the various attacks that have been made
on him so I think it would be very very
interesting for me as a non-american
somebody who can't remember the Vietnam
War I vaguely remember being that I was
12 when Saigon fell for example but I'm
therefore I think going to be able to
come to it with a degree of objectivity
that many Americans wouldn't be able to
because of course the both Vietnam and
Cambodia are really such emotional
issues for Americans in a way they
simply are not for me I think I'm going
to be able to get
historians objectivity you have a
connection between the Duke of
Wellington and the Carol's yes it's a
Carol's of Maryland yeah this is what
they named Carrollton Maryland after
they live around Washington know about
that yeah what's the connection well I
mean the the man who made the the first
great fortune he had three daughters and
a daughter-in-law
one of whom at one of his daughters
married Wellington's brother Richard the
Marquess Wellesley who was foreign
secretary he'd been governor-general of
India he was an incredibly powerful and
successful man quite rich as well and
the daughter-in-law married very
unsuccessfully and unhappily as it
turned out jérôme Bonaparte Napoleon's
brother and the he was ordered by
Napoleon to divorce her because although
Napoleon was interested in in the
Western Hemisphere at the time of the
marriage he wasn't after the Louisiana
Purchase and so he he just ordered his
his brother to to marry a and a European
aristocrats instead but it is amazing to
think this American family from
Baltimore were married into the families
of these two great commanders actually
I'm looking at the names Mary Ann Louisa
and Elizabeth the three granddaughters
of Charles Carroll who was the longest
surviving signer of the Declaration of
Independence that's right yes exactly
and and they an astonishing and figure I
think there's something there must be
something about the Baltimore air
because that makes European credence or
nearly credence in these case because of
course it's also the birthplace of them
Wallis Simpson now here's just a little
parenthetical expression I want to read
and get your reaction to it Napoleon
once said that the hereditary Prince
avert and Berg was so fat because God
had specifically designed him as an
experiment to see how far human skin
could stretch without breaking if
perfect example of Napoleon's wit
Israel out of that yes there's a lot of
I've tried to keep as many M as many of
his cracks and jokes and gags in there I
think it helps her history book along
and also its attend it reminds you that
these people are not just huge figures
made in marble like that Cano Versace
that they were living breathing people
who who loved and joked and thought
another parenthetical expression on the
same pages he had a long disapproved of
Wellesley whoring and in 1810 had
suggest that his brother's career would
prosper better where he castrated
although with his own many mistresses
and mistreatment of his at times
suicidal wife there was more than a
whiff of hypocrisy to this who you
talking about I'm talking about
Wellington Wellington was a what was
called in the 18th century a sexual
swordsman paar externals when he went to
to Paris as ambassador he was of course
the the Conqueror of the city but at the
same time he was the Conqueror of the
hearts of many of the of the both French
and English women who went there and
also was thought to possibly have slept
with the granddaughter of from of
Carroll of Carrollton who later married
his brother there's quite a lot of this
going on and obviously I've chronicled a
bit of it in the book but where it
overlaps with the with the general story
he had this form of it's sort of almost
Napoleonic sexual tourism in that he
would went out of his way to collect
things that have belonged to Napoleon he
had Napoleon's watch maker make him
watch his sword maker making the sword
he took over Napoleon's sister's house
as the British Embassy which it still is
today he's got he had the hired loophole
Ian's cook he went around visiting and
his libraries and his and his homes and
he slept with two of Napoleon's
mistresses and I think really to sleep
with one mistress might be considered
accidental but to implies there was a
kind of trophy hunting going on
comparison 1814 by the way the robbers
Napoleon's original name original name
well he was he was it was Napoleon II do
on a party just like we now know it yes
there were a few there I mean he he
altered it himself which of course
Wellington also did and Wellington was
born
Arthur Wesley and it was then changed to
Wellesley and there was a very much this
was very much done on class grounds
because it was seen to be a grander name
Arthur Wellesley is that the same name
that they named the College in the
United States after in Wellesley College
no I think that's that's the named after
the founder of Methodism now that I'm no
experiment let's start with the Duke of
Wellington he was born where he was born
in Ireland and Dublin we think because
of course his father never never saw fit
to register it but we think he was born
in a in a grand house in in Dublin a
very beautiful house in fact when next
to come over the side you might want to
go there because it's a it's a lovely
place and he had a very unhappy
childhood is that you say he was parson
though he wasn't that careful his
Protestant in a country that of course
was overwhelmingly Catholic and he was
part of the small what was called the
Protestant ascendancy a small group of
Protestants who effectively owned and
ran Ireland in those days and so he and
this is an interesting another
connection with Napoleon because
Napoleon came from the planet of the of
Corsica that helped rule Corsica for
France another Island in hoc basically
to the mainland power that's exactly the
same as as Wellington and Wennington had
a very unhappy childhood he didn't do
terribly well at school his father died
when he was only 15 and of course
Napoleon start a father died when he was
I mean the podium was only 13 so they
have that in common as well he was good
at mathematics as was Napoleon he had
exactly the same number of brothers and
sisters as Napoleon and they both
enjoyed mathematics
and also chose Hannibal as their and as
their heroes and a lot of things in
common leads to you even though who one
thinks of them as being completely
different how tall was the Duke and well
he was five nine he was he was a lot
taller than then I'm a silly way he we
don't know the exact figure because
people didn't know weigh themselves and
note it down and it's quite the same way
but he was he was slim and fit he never
took any carriages to campaign he was on
his horse Copenhagen pretty much
throughout he never took a day's holiday
when he was campaigning in the in Spain
and Portugal over six years and he was a
something of a workaholic and a very
tough-minded man
but he also had a quite a good sense of
humor you named the horse the his horses
Copenhagen there that do you remember
the names of the horses of Napoleon
well there's one God I'm hearing
merengue which was the one that he that
he rode at the Battle of Waterloo which
actually funny enough could be seen at
the National Army Museum here in here in
London in Chelsea the skeleton of the of
the horse is there apart from two hoofs
that have been used as snuff boxes and
the snuff boxes are at the st. James's
Palace yes if you dine at San James's
with the with the brigade of guards
which I've done a couple of times it's
very nice because at the end of the meal
they passed around Merengues and hoof
with a silver top and and little
explanation in silver and you take snuff
after dinner
also I I see Desiree and Marie yes
well Desiree was named after his first
girlfriend who happened to be Josephine
sister Napoleon yes Napoleon's she was
very he was very much in love with
Desiree but when it turned out that he
didn't have enough money to to make her
happy she went off with a richer man of
course in the end and didn't turn has be
anything likes a rich as Napoleon and
was and he passed her on to her sister
go back again to Wellington when did he
start being called the Duke who want
he was created Duke in 1814 that the
year before the Battle of Waterloo one
in 1760 1769 years he was a his was an
astonishing advancement through the
through the British peerage there's
never been anybody before in the history
of the British peerage who became Baron
Viscount Earl Marcus and then Duke all
in one go at the House of Lords because
he'd been on campaign when he'd been
gazetted all of these titles he hadn't
had a chance to actually take them up
officially so when he went to the House
of Lords he had to spend the whole day
being being elevated each of the orders
of peerage from the very bottom to the
very top he was in the House of Lords
before he became prime minister which I
assume he was in the House of Commons at
that point no no no in those days peers
could be could be Prime Minister
nowadays we haven't had a peer since
Lord Salisbury the man that I wrote
about a few years ago and that was in
1902
so we've now had a century of of appears
in the House of Commons
but back in Wellington's day it was
perfectly acceptable when was he Prime
Minister drew Broome he was Prime
Minister from 1830 to 1832 he was it
wasn't very long it wasn't a very
successful Premiership the fact was that
they were bringing in a reform bill
which he was totally opposed to and so
he he was pretty keen to leave politics
as soon as he could the Duke of
Wellington was married how many times he
was only married once he was married to
a woman who he fell in love with when he
was very young had an Irish girl very
our Socratic family the Pakenham family
and he then went on campaign to India
went I think for 11 years to India to
campaign by the time he came back he
felt on a bound to she turned him down
because because he didn't have enough
money or at least she wanted to marry
him but it but her parents the elves of
Encounters have longed for didn't
and so but he didn't write to her or
keep in touch but when he came back he
felt on a bound to ask her again and
this time he done very well in India and
and had been promoted he was a major
general and she was allowed to accept
him but it was a disaster and what's
that quote about her being ugly he said
he only hadn't seen her for all this
time and and he said to his friend
she's grown ugly by God which is hardly
the best way to kick off a American
hunter marry her
anyway well I mean nobody married her in
the in the meantime she was not the
right woman for for a great man she was
unable to keep up with the way in which
he was his career was going and his gang
sky-high and she frankly wasn't really
and capable of of helping it along and
it was I made children they had I think
five children the oldest the the boy
became the next Duke of Wellington he
said how depressing it was when his
father died not just for the obvious
reasons but also because when people
called out the Duke of Wellington as he
entered a room everyone turned round to
see the greatest man in Europe instead
of course it was it was it was only him
and when you when you tore the absolute
house here yes you hear the voice of a
Duke of Wellington that's the present
Duke this the eighth Duke of Wellington
who's the descendent of the of the first
team now you talk to him oh yes
absolutely yes he was very helpful for
this book there are an awful lot of
great stories that remain in families
and this family is one of the grandest
aquatic families in England and they
also have have land at Waterloo and in
Spain where the great ancestor Ford and
of course they have the treasures that
you have seen at absolutely house and
which I recommend anybody to go and see
because they really are they are really
are splendid they've got the the swords
and the gold plate and the and the
paintings especially the paintings which
are around second to none in private
collection in the United Kingdom now if
your today currently the Duke of
Wellington what does it mean well
unfortunately he no longer
because of the government's the Labour
government's alterations to the to the
hereditary peerage he no longer has a
seat in the House of Lords but
nonetheless he's still the absolute apex
of British society just just directly
below the royal family does he get money
at all from the government Oh No
absolutely not and it's it hasn't in the
case that that they have the last time
they got money from the government was
when they had their stately home bought
for them back in the 1820s
so there have been eight Dukes of
Wellington yes yeah and the original one
we're talking about here had how many
brothers he had I think four brothers
and three sisters and they were they
were quite a bunch as well the eldest
one Richard Wellesley was a tremendously
successful politician the the others
were MP's one I think became a bishop
they were very supportive of his career
and they yeah they all helped one
another that's the way that things were
done in the 18th century
just like the palings brothers but the
period that Weddington brothers were a
bit more impressive
you go back to Waterloo leading up to
Waterloo the Duke of Wellington was in
control of how many troops well he had
about a hundred and thirty thousand or
so it's the trouble is you have to take
into account who who has the ultimate
command of the Dutch and the Hanoverians
it was a very small you see it wasn't
just the English versus the French by
any means to the Wellington's army was
only one-third British and the other
two-thirds were made up of a a polyglot
force some of whom were very good indeed
like the king's german legion who held a
farmhouse til virtually the last man at
the Battle of Waterloo and was superb
fighters others like the Brunswick
cavalry fled the battle at field the
minute the first shot was fired and
trampling everything in there in their
wake and so there is a very different
standard of truth when I asked you about
truth-telling because you suggest in
here that a lot of things have been
handed down that were not accurate for
instance the story about the Duke of
Wellington the night before the Battle
of Waterloo visiting the Prussian
general yes yes it seems absolutely
clear to me and to many other historians
who've looked into this closely that
there was no meeting that who says there
was well when is Luke Wellington himself
said there was yes this is the problem
and old old generals tend to you know
old men forget but old generals forget
selectively and they also make things up
there's there's hardly a you know war in
history where there hasn't been a bit of
bragging going on from a fellow
downwards so I think that we'll find
really and it's worthwhile checking all
of the statements made on on both sides
so how in the end did the Duke of
Wellington win the Battle of Waterloo he
did it by putting in two superb and
tremendously impressive practice all the
things he'd learnt from his campaigning
in India and his especially his
campaigning in Spain and Portugal
because one of them one of the things
was which was tremendously useful to him
at the Battle of Waterloo was to hide
your troops as much as possible he was
very good at what's called reverse-flow
tactics so when the French were looking
at a at a slope of which there are many
at the battlefields of Waterloo and he
would make his men lie down below the
the slope up until then the trick was to
try and put your men in as overt and
obvious away as possible to in order to
try to intimidate the enemy he did the
opposite he hid his men and so when the
French marched up they would suddenly
appear he was very lucky of course that
they were also long on the battlefield
high high amounts of corn you'd call it
maize and under which and in which he
could hide regiments he also used
some of the most advanced tactics in
terms of the way in which battalions
could fire and he used lines rather than
columns I didn't to be boring they're
all in the book but he was he was a
superb master tactician however you been
there oh yes several times it's the most
fascinating battlefield it is very easy
to see and understand the whole thing
because it hasn't been changed at all
since the day of the battle and it had
apart from it has won a very high mound
about 150 feet high which when you're
there you can see the entire battlefield
you can survey the whole thing from the
top of this mound and it makes it very
easy to understand how long was about
well it started off this again debate
over when it started that I believe it
started about half-past ten between
half-past ten eleven o'clock in the
morning and it wasn't over until seven
o'clock that night when when darkness
fell and how many people died there a
lot it was probably about 48 to 50,000
people it was a wonder it was a massive
massive conflagration it was the biggest
loss of life until until the American
Civil War it was a crushing defeat for
the French and it's unit destroyed the
Napoleonic Empire overnight after that
battle was over what did Napoleon do he
waited for a month he fled the
battlefield tried to return to Paris
realized that the game was up and in an
attempt not to fall into the hands of
the Prussians who wanted to shoot him he
surrendered to the British Navy who took
him immediately away from France and
took him in fact to to Plymouth and
south coast town in Britain and kept him
on the boat
outside this town before sending him off
into exile on censored leader which is a
tiny island in the Atlantic Ocean and
that's where he died you say there's
been a dispute over the years whether
the Duke of Wellington what Napoleon
thought to Duke of Wellington surname
was st. Elena yes yes you've been
planning for some reason blamed
Wellington for the choice of santolina
this rather rugged
outpost this rock in the what he called
the accursed rock and he belated where
moment in the mid-atlantic not the coast
of Africa yes yes but well quite quite
some far away of it it's the most it's
further away from anywhere else how long
was he there he was there for six years
before he finally succumbed to to
stomach cancer which was the thing that
had killed his father
although there are many theories to say
that he was poisoned
possibly by one of the people in his own
in his own mini courts there whose wife
he was sleeping with and now how long
was it after he died that the French
brought him back to Paris nineteen years
he was brought back in December 1842 the
most enormous state funeral literally
and a million people came out to to see
his his coffin being brought to his own
village which is the most stunning
Church in the ecole militaire the
military academy in in paris why would
they be excited about back he lost he
lost but before he lost he had one I
need 50 of his 72 battles and had
thought the French Eagles his his
standards all the way from from Cairo to
Moscow to Berlin to to Vienna and these
were astonishing achievements for
anybody on page 109 and this may be a
stretch but as I read it it had some
relevance it seemed like to what's going
on in the world today
for instance you write here that there
can be no doubt that Wellington studied
Napoleon's strategy in a way that
Napoleon omitted to do with Wellington
this was done primarily on know thine
enemy bases as there is precious little
indication that after the Battle of
Waterloo Wellington read anything at all
about either Napoleon or the battle
besides dr. O'Meara's to vol Napoleon
and exile you go on to talk about
Wellington was determined here's what
I'm getting it Wellington was determined
to enter as a liberator of the French
from the poliana
tourney himself that the country rather
rather than just another foreign conquer
and I just I when I thought about that I
thought about the Iraqi situation
the overlaps are obvious I think I
wasn't trying to make that that book was
actually written before the Iraqi city
of crisis that we that we're presently
in but it seems to me that if the Allied
forces if the British and American
forces ever do actually march on Baghdad
it's crucial they should do so as
liberators as people who as an army that
is that is liberating Iraq from the from
the tyranny of Saddam Hussein I'm sure
that's what they'll you know hope
wouldn't attempt to do and it's likely
that they do do that because then you
don't look like an occupying force in
which the nation rises up against you I
should point out that because this is
being taped at the early part of
December and by the time it airs we
don't know what will have happened in
the Iraqi situation but go back to what
did after this was over or during that
time what did the Duke of Wellington
think he was doing what was it what were
his motives well his motives were to
re-establish the French monarchy and to
to ensure that France no longer posed a
threat to its neighbors so he wasn't in
favor of the French Revolution no no no
he himself was an aristocrat of course
and he'd been taught at his French
school which he actually liked very much
unlike his British schools that by
people who were subsequently guillotines
in the French Revolution and he had
friends who lost their lives to the
French Revolution and was therefore very
keen that France should return to the
pre-revolutionary days when apart from
with a strong Parliament which of course
it didn't have under louis xvi so what
did what was Napoleon's motives and what
did he think of the French Revolution he
supported it and he was part of it he
actually when the Revolution was about
to be snuffed out
he got cannons into the center of Paris
and what he called a whiff of grapeshot
he he mowed down the the rioters in in
a vicious but wholly successful attempt
to defend the revolution you point out
that there were games being played by
the Duke Longtin to the end of his life
public and private of what he really
thought of Napoleon we go back to that
statue at absolutely house yeah 18 feet
of Napoleon in his own residence what
did he like him did he not like him he
did he was the first to admit that
Napoleon was worth 40,000 men in his own
phrase on the battlefield he was a
astonishment nurturer genius and he said
that publicly privately however he wrote
long articles denouncing Napoleon and
saying that then in fact he didn't learn
anything but he was very good when he
started but he never learned anything
new which is actually true I think most
historians would accept that Wellington
on the other hand learned on the job all
the way through and it's a it's a mark
of his genius for leadership that he did
but Napoleon is that also the same very
interestingly I went through I believe
every reference that Napoleon ever made
to Wellington in the course of writing
that book I had to gut some 600 books in
order to try and get these references
and I found 12 and in every single one
of them Napoleon is privately extremely
impressed by Wellington's generalship
and he says all sorts of things he said
this is the best general he's the most
impressive allied general I'm up against
he's defeated six of my marshals in in
the Iberian Peninsula and Spain and
Portugal but in public he dismisses him
and he gets his newspapers to say that
Wellington is Amir its the poi general
which means a general who's only good
for and for commanding troops in India
and not for commanding European troops
which was a racist abuse that that in
those days would have been and would
have hit home
you said 600 books that you did you read
him no of course not no no not all of
them know what I did was to gut them for
their and why did you do that
who's got the end oh well index what for
the ones that are indexed but
thing is of course you don't get indexes
until about the 1860s 1870s that's when
books started to be indexed on a regular
basis and most of the books that I was
working on of course were from earlier
periods than that from the
contemporaries of Napoleon and
Wellington so it was just a very
laborious process of of working out
which chapters were likely to be the
ones where Napoleon would talk about
Wellington or vice-versa it was
exhausting task but it's in the end what
were your best sources for the Napoleon
side and the best sources on the
Wellington's well all of Napoleon's
letters were were collected and
transcribed in the 1870s by his nephew
who became Emperor Napoleon the third of
France who who ruled France from 1852 to
1870 and so those were completely
invaluable and for Wellington really the
Duke of Wellington very kindly let me
use his his great ancestors library and
there were the penciled notes in the
margins made by the great Duke of books
about Napoleon which of course proved to
be totally invaluable for life in the
pencil room are often did he comment
very rarely and the content comments
were just exclamation marks or no things
like that but it was it was very
important really and helpful to know the
bits that Wellington believed were
inaccurate and quite a few of them were
about him how long did this book take
you to research before you began writing
it it took four years but you know in a
sense it's been in the back of my mind
for much longer than that and it's been
a special love of mine since I was seven
as I think where do you do your work I
work at home in Knightsbridge but I also
sometimes use an office it's it depends
on on other commitments and things you
have a family yes yes I've got to I've
got two children an ex-wife and a
girlfriend
so all in all and they take up there
quite a bit of time too I work usually
between four o'clock in the in the
morning and lunchtime which is when I
turn I find that nobody phones and you
can get a straight run of eight hours
work and how are you doing the writing
these days computer writing it out
longhand or how is it and well I
actually do write longhand yes it's
completely absurd but I feel that it
means that the thoughts go through your
mind one more time than when you're just
just tapping it out on the on the
computer and so it's it's one extra I
find that you can get verbal diarrhea if
you don't watch out lots of books I
think are too long nowadays because
people aren't really thinking them
through before writing them down
we're out of time Andrew Roberts thank
you very much for joining us the book
looks like this published by Simon &
Schuster called
Napoleon and Wellington and again our
guest is Andrew Roberts thank you thank
you very much indeed